la course des garçons de café c'est une
tradition dans le monde de la
restauration française
la course des garçons de café s'est
généralisé au début du 20e siècle voir
c'est d'abord à paris que la discipline
s'est popularisée l'objectif faire
reconnaître les qualités l'adresse la
rapidité des garçons de café de la
capitale
les juges à l'arrivée devait tenir
compte du temps réalisé bien sûr mais
aussi du contenu subsistant dans les
verres un challenge que des garçons de
café de toute la france et même du monde
tenteront aussi de relever dès 1957 des
serveurs camerounais s'affrontaient dans
les rues de douala
eux aussi étaient prêts en partant mais
au fil des kilomètres
chaque goutte de transpiration combes et
la chaleur torride va transformer cette
course aimable en marathon aux scènes
finales parfois dramatiques les filles
prennent aussi part à la course peu
nombreuses dans les années 60 elle
s'impose ensuite comme de redoutables
adversaires en 1994 cette serveuse dans
cn s'était bien préparé
je viens de faire le marathon parisien
oui je suis entraîné je m'entraîne pour
pratiquement tous les autres 15 à 17
et pour tenter d'arriver le premier
chacun sa méthode
il s'agit de mettre le bras le long du
corps et le balancement du corps v2
marchait pas fort mais à l'arrivée
l'heure est au bilan et les plateaux ne
sont pas toujours intacte
je n'ai vu j'avais tellement faim
aujourd'hui dans le monde plus de 50
pays organisent régulièrement des
courses de garçons et filles de café au
japon en israël ou en argentine par
exemple
[Musique]